aujourd'hui c'est le deuxième
regroupement du club réunion et on est
là pour créer une cohésion
au niveau du club réunion parce que le
club réunion sont des athlètes qui ne se
connaissent pas ils se connaissent dans
leur discipline mais se connaissent pas
entre disciplines donc créer une
cohésion qu'il rencontre l'équipe
responsable du club réunion qu'on fasse
connaissance et qu'on passe quelques
heures ensemble pour créer un peu ce
début de
deux clubs réunion va voir comment la
sauce prend pour la création du haka on
a on va créer un haka est ce que ça va
garder le nom ak je n'en sais rien
peut-être qu'on changera de nous trouver
un nom créole à la place pourquoi pas
mais créer créer quelque chose qui sera
le cri de guerre du club réunion
e
dation effets qu'aurait
simulacre ils augmenteront
mais c'est la manière dont 6000 à angers
intrus et déjà et avant qu'on me
contenir les a trahis at elle simplement
parce qu'il faut attendre d'avoir les
paroles déjà il faut que la chorégraphie
correspondent aux paroles et puis il
faut que ce soit c'est intimidant et
tout ça c'est compliqué parce qu'on
n'est pas tous d'accord il faut qu'on se
mette d'accord que je sais faire
connaissance avec des gens qu'on peut
n'est pas une légende et a dit
dans l'apprentissage c'est un peu
difficile pour nous voici dans tout va
bien
les autres groupes i dance des gens à
bin nous avons déjà dire 3 murcia
et comme discipline
la voile
les autres lisent se prépare très très
bien pour les jeux c'est un enjeu très
important
parce qu'ils veulent ils veulent les
gagner et j'espère qu'ils veulent pas
les gagner plus que nous nous voulons
les gagner et que nous on va vraiment
les gagner
effectivement 58 vie que je ne
connaissais pas mais j'observe depuis
quelques années confesse animations
c'est que le cas ça prend de suite aux
tripes et en quel que soit le public en
général ça prend et notamment sur le
public sportif je vais pas trop de
doutes sur sur l'engouement de
l'animation
on est là vraiment on est motivés que le
haka représente vraiment la motivation
est vraiment le combat qu'on veut mener
pour ces jeux des îles et
la victoire